This episode of "Shots of Awe"
is brought to you by Norton.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So I'm really
interested in the space
in which design
meets consciousness.
When we're not just building
or creating useless things,
but when we're actually
co-actively authoring
our mindware.
We build the tools.
And remember, the
tools build us.
And there's actually
a whole philosophy
behind this idea, known
as ontological design.
Anne-Marie Willis wrote
an amazing article,
in which she basically
stated it like this.
Everything that we design,
in turn, designs us back.
So we are being
actively designed
by that which we have designed.
Our thoughts shape our
spaces and shape our tools.
Our tools and spaces
return the favor,
as Steven Johnson tells us.
And so what does this mean?
Well, it means that
everything we are
is emerging, is unfolding.
It's being created by
the active engagements
between mind and world.
And the feedback
loops therein are
creating the linguistic choices,
transform, literally transform
our minds from within.
And so again, it shows
that there a sort of space
in which what is without,
ultimately is within.
That there's a circularity.
That our actions matter.
That the choices we make
today for our dwellings,
for our museums, for our
institutional systems,
everywhere we place the
body-mind has to be designed,
knowing that everything
that we are designing
is designing us back.
This is ontological design.
This is why it's important.
And this is why we basically got
to keep in mind when we upgrade
everything, from
our refrigerators,
to our apartments, to our cars,
to our goods and services,
to our smartphones because
it's our minds we're
talking about here.
That's ontological design.
[MUSIC PLAYING]